I don't want to reveal too much about
the clip but it's you oh yeah reacting
to something that somebody said in the
audience and you immediately make a a
Deez Nuts joke yeah like he was like do
you make that up on the spot and I was
like well this is the thing about doing
so many is your brain is tuned yeah for
that yeah any sentence that's said to me
yeah I process each word first and my
brain runs a function that's check for
D's before I process the thought yeah
I've started talking slower
yeah because I have to really analyze
what you just said yeah yeah hey man you
want Evian
no yeah and see you just said I just
flew in from Boise yeah so immediately I
said well do you like Boise yeah
you said yes boys eating your [__] yeah